I'm very much well known as the EU guy
Ben gallant is a european at heart for
him membership of the EU is essential
for britain to remain a modern
cosmopolitan country which is why the
cambridge university student has joined
the campaign to defeat the brexit
movement it's an issue that has
polarized the country for months with
less than a week until the referendum
polls put the probe grexit camp ahead
will Ben's efforts help to turn around
the vote and convince his fellow
students and neighbors that their
country needs to remain in the EU
what did you Ben doesn't really have any
time for politics man sorting and
distributing flyers his final exams for
his chemistry degree here at Cambridge
University are just a few days away but
there's not a moment to lose on the
lobbying front we received a billion
pounds of EU funding to further
education in this country every year and
all the way through to peace so 71 years
of peace in Europe partially down mostly
down to the EU so there has been this
lack of information on the on the random
on the arguments were and there's bit
that would be several big out cries for
where is all the information how we
meant to vote on this when we don't know
so here is the information hopefully
stirring the bridges been Ellis and
Darcy are members of the Cambridge for
Europe student group they've just
received some new lobbying kits from the
nationwide pro-europe campaign ahead of
the referendum on Thursday look what
stronger a sent me there 73 they sent
free no hold on the fight for votes is
now entering its decisive phase just
when the student should be pouring over
their books just as well the library is
open around the clock I was in heroes in
the library by to our six a.m. today
actually so then I do myself my three
hours tin then go back ever have another
bit of breakfast at my my home I live in
a house very nearby which is really
handy to be honest and then come back
more time in the library lunch more time
in the library you get that get the
feeling Ben needs good exam results if
he's to continue as postgraduate studies
at Cambridge but this evening he's
putting his revision to one side to go
out canvassing was politician Natalie
Bennett hi there can I interest you in a
say yes to Europe poster no don't worry
the outgoing leader of the Green Party
of England and way
is giving a speech at the University to
encourage students to register for the
referendum we very much celebrate free
movement of people in the EU whether you
get an Erasmus scholarship and go and
study in Rome for a year whether you
take advantage of germany 0 university
tuition fees and go and study in Germany
or maybe I pair in Paris for a year
unfortunately her talk an hour later is
poorly attended she was preaching to a
room of 20 students who have dragged
themselves my library and a future of
green voters in Cambridge the turnout
wasn't great which is never never ideal
and especially when you've got party
leader the next morning Ben is up at the
crack of dawn last night he and his
housemates were out on the town and got
a little carried away the others are
still asleep most of them and will be
for a few hours I should imagine um yeah
they they got in even later than I did
and and will not surface for a few hours
what you already yes yes I'm about out
rearing to go
only one early in the morning getting up
dad they think I'm absolutely mental
mostly um so I study chemistry and live
with a house full of care science
students so I am very much the only
politically engaged one really and so
they are very confused by my ardent
interest in politics and include the
world in general and they liked it to
stick to their to the science which is
fair enough in right Ben has always felt
a commitment to Europe but it was the
announcement of the referendum that
inspired him to become politically
active for the first time in his life
yeah let's go get him can do it again
he's off to the city center where a
range of pro-europe groups are holding
an event their primary target group is
younger voters the organizers know that
they tend to look favorably on the EU
therefore they want to do register for
the all-important vote wonderful
garrison oh yeah how are you yeah among
those attending the event is a former
member of parliament move from fascism
but he's largely preaching to the
converted here and we're of those young
voters got to
a street festival proves to be a bigger
draw than the pro-europe show plus Ben
and his friends face direct competition
from a street stand for the leave the EU
side organized by Cambridge alumni yeah
we just thought we could see what you
were you has to say I don't think this
project for a one system Europe that
doesn't have very much accountability
democracy is the way forward for us I
think we should be like Switzerland like
Norway like Australia like Canada
independent self-governing countries the
cooperating to take on quite a lot of EU
regulation anyhow I did get the
benefactor and should take them any
think we want to see Europe doing better
we want to see young people doing better
in places like Greece places like Italy
we want to see a more open immigration
policy I'm actually from Australia we
have people from all over in this
campaign with people from Europe we
sense the mood is changing and we think
the brexit can be a pivotal event you
know sort of Berlin Wall moment noon if
Britain left it would be very negative
for the right-wing mood that is
currently emerging in
all over Europe and I think that's quite
a dangerous thing almost and black
reason I think it's very important that
the British actually stays it Alison
been are worried about the increasingly
hostile tone of the debate plus polls
show the leaf camp recently extending
their lead over remain so the activists
have taken to social media to mobilize
their fellow students they're asking
people to write down their arguments in
favour of Europe before posting them
online if you don't go and stand on the
stairs home button for that this message
is typical a united Europe is stronger
and which self-respecting student these
days would make a statement without a
Twitter hashtag and once that
perspective voter has left Ben
approaches the next one what
Tracy but apathy is widespread voter
registration for the referendum among
students at Cambridge is just fifty
percent in the afternoon they drive to
one of the leave campaign strongholds
Peterborough it's just an hour's drive
away but it's a different world compared
to the enlightened corridors of
Cambridge they reckon it's best not to
say they're from the elite University
they're wary of a potential backlash not
the most encouraging of starts can I ask
can I ask britt where you voted is that
no not all can I interest you in a
leaflet on my why should vote in in the
European referendum at all we don't
really know the true facts you got one
policy saying one thing and another
party saying you're never there only
time that's what they want us tonight
they're not telling us what we need to i
know i'm saying so on then ground Jay
I'm gonna write out are you gonna be
roasting out can I ask why yep stay in
Europe are you um I've been taught to
stop stop trying to convince me to stay
and I'm voting out and don't I don't
make me irate the main topic of
discussion is immigration Peterborough
has a high proportion of new residents
from Eastern Europe many of the local
residents are afraid of being sidelined
we don't mind Polish people or any
people it's just the numbers that coming
in and we haven't got the hospitals or
the road structures to accommodate it to
look at things other than immigration
office announced and information is
probably the biggest issue but things
like that the EU has done for the
environment for example if this is
really important for me yeah like if
it's unequivocal the EU has made our
beaches cleaner air safer it's protected
our natural habitats I'm actually they
may not have been able to change
anyone's mind but the students are still
satisfied with their little trip to
Peterborough a number of people did at
least listen to them with the big day
now less than a week away it's time to
assess their social media campaign we've
got literally two well operate up to 100
photos now of people saying I'm voting
in and there is that crowd mentality of
oh my friend is voting in my all of my
friends ever see my earth would I vote
out so I'd like to think the pic of both
there as well which is good and there
are similar grassroots activists not
just in Cambridge but across the country
they number several hundred thousand in
total this is something that's so
important and I mean a lot of people say
how it's a vote for your future and I
think that's completely true and so in
that regard there is no question about
the fact link yeah it needs to be done
following the shocking news that a
Labour MP had been murdered possibly
because of her pro-eu stands campaigning
on both sides was briefly suspended the
aggressive campaign leaf campaign we've
really come out
link with the the immigration art which
is touching quite what legitimately in
most cases a lot of artists up and down
the country and that may while we're
winning books and that's a concern our
side the students will be lobbying away
right down to the last minute trying to
bring sober arguments into this bitterly
divisive debate for them the murder of
Joe Cox has underlined the importance of
preventing further polarization as
Britain prepares for a historic decision
guys let's do this video